welcome to phone swap hi camilo
hi my name is callan i'm looking for an
intelligent girl
who is very athletic i'm an open-minded
person so i'm
also looking for someone who is
open-minded what do you do
i'm a sports performance coach hey i'm
camila my dating life is
terrible i have been in two
relationships in the past two years and
both guys cheated
you know i'm a life fitness coach and i
like working out my dating life is
terrible and i got cheated on twice
i did a whole bunch more certifications
exercise therapy
that's awesome yeah now the moment of
truth
we just let them know they have to trade
phones huh i'm kind of worried
because no one's ever been through my
phone i'm feeling good
i am proud of my body and i want him to
see that there you go
[Music]
i can feel it i think this one's going
to be a good one so let's see
oh my god my images this is her biggest
i'm just posting that ass i know you're
gonna say something about my ass
you said something about your ass yeah
but she's just enjoying the moment yeah
i know
no you said something about your ass i
wanted to see that i'm proud of my body
and then he said something about joy and
you po
ah why did you think she was mad she's
just like yeah look at my ass
no she said i knew you would say
something of course yeah you said
something about joanne
girl of course she's just enjoying the
moment she's got like a
big old booty oh my god oh there he goes
with dating apps
33 new matches she messaged this guy and
in two days he didn't mess your back so
he's not interested i mean she's
i'm assuming she's more into black guys
he said i'm more into black guy as well
i kind of have an impression that i
might not be her type that's irritating
she talks a lot of blood guys
why don't they edit it like that i think
she's hit the black guy she looks like
she talks to a lot of black guys i
assume that she's really into black guys
that's a lot of black guys
no brother you're gonna
i've actually heard white guys say for
girls dated black kids they would not
they
yes that's common yes yeah some of them
are half they're like it depends on what
kind of black guy yeah
some of them do that halfway but yeah
i've heard people say that definitely
yeah definitely that's the thing and
here's the thing when that comes up
there's like two reasons that they give
right
they'll be like yeah i'm just like she
wants to be with a dude who's like
he's about that street life like i don't
want a white girl like that you know and
then
the the that's not
that's not the pro let's not let's not
be over hey
let's not be over here and pretend that
that's the problem
huh
you know what you're thinking it might
not be true
well we know what you're thinking it
hasn't maybe not me
well we know what you're thinking she
got that bbc how she gonna be
wait come on dalvie it's not that deep
guys no it's not that deep it's not that
literally
it's not that cheap it's not that big of
a deal
oh literally it's not that big of a deal
yeah
but plenty of white girls do that you
know i mean they you know they explore
right they go to the inner city and then
they go back to the suburbs
that happens all the time later on in
life so
you know don't be so close-minded
there's wonderful things out there for
you guys
now as far as her liking black dudes
black women often say stuff like i only
would date a black guy so there's always
that perception in the media already
and so that when a black why do
sometimes you're too intimidated by that
aspect so like
she probably wouldn't be into me uh so
maybe she didn't have a type like that
i don't like him saying that who says
stuff like that
who's that stuff like that a lot of
people yeah a lot of people even me man
sometimes i'll go on a girl's facebook
profile and if she's dribbling a
basketball i'm like she likes [ __ ]
that happens so i do and if they have a
picture of them with a bunch of african
kids
yo if i see that i'm like oh you wanted
to go to kenya and save some children
how about i put some babies in you right
that's
the link that i make so there's just
certain things that people do talk like
that
or if they don't say it hourly they
think it in their head oftentimes
definitely they
100 think that how about this
if you looked at a girl's instagram
right let's say she was like a chinese
girl okay
and she had a bunch of pictures with her
and her black friends
right everyone's going to put the
quotation marks whether i put them there
or not
they're coming it's kind of how it works
literally i don't know maybe it's
wrong to assume him saying that is just
a major turn off
this feels weird i don't think i've
checked any guy's phone before
well i'll start with messages first i
don't save numbers but he has
the first name and last name and then
their picture that's funny
i like to make sure things are organized
on my phone so
he has a secret album what does that
even mean well all the
pics are locked in a vault she can't get
into the house i haven't actually sent
anyone they're more for like my own
progress photos i suppose
what's this guy doing [ __ ] dick lifts
dick 90x
dick 90x man progress photos i mean i
used to believe that when i was 16 i
used to believe those pills worked i
bought one
oh yeah yeah yeah just one pill yeah
because i used to really think that my
wasn't big enough and i was like oh man
and then i started dating and i was like
i guess i don't need them
or maybe they worked but anyways all
this stuff no matter how much your size
is
i mean you you still think it is small
most of you will yeah because you watch
the video you're like oh my god yeah i'm
big but i'm not mandigo i'm not right
swing it around the room no no it's cold
outside what's wrong
yeah but that's you get once you once
you're out there in the streets then
you're like okay actually i'm probably
doing fine why would you have
progress pics of your that's yeah
progress pics of you no it's weird um
a selfie oh it looks okay
that's a horrible photo that's horrible
oh look there's a girl
oh there's a whole bunch of flowers in
her face
seems like he's talking to a lot of
girls are they black girls
that's what we want to know it's a good
question
hi how was it oh it's fine yeah yeah
i was like i didn't know where to start
or what to look at
what did you find on my dating apps i
don't know there's a bunch of messages
[Applause]
and what do you think about the people
that i date with hmm
[Music]
and you think that i'm only into a
certain race not necessarily
only in one it just seemed more like
don't backpedal now bro that's right
you said what you said that's your
energy keep the same
energy let's go boo-boo yes it doesn't
look like she flies lufthansa she looks
like she flies ethiopian airlines
you can tell all right you looked at one
time she didn't watch
fox news she watched the bbc that's what
you thought
your type was definitely not me i mean
everyone has a type and i'm like i'm not
i have no attempts i've dated everyone
so you make that assumption
because you see only one type of race
i guess that is kind of an assumption
okay so
[Applause]
they want a second date the mk
solved it right there yeah what i
suspect is that
he wasn't interested in hurt so he was
just sabotaging the whole thing
sometimes when you don't want somebody
but you already on the date you're going
to find reasons why
they shouldn't be with you do they want
a second date it's time to trade back
phones and find out
i don't think i would and it says think
we can be friends
i'm totally okay with it yeah
you're not gonna be friends let's be
honest uh as far as the assumption about
the whole racial dating thing like yeah
it's common in the dating scene
based off who you hang out with or who
they see you with or who your exes are
some people have insecurities about that
some people feel some type of way but
most people
they make those assumptions this is one
of those things you know
people sometimes they ask you what your
ex look like why i'm not well no more
i'm with you it's
wrong i mean there's insecurities every
everywhere yeah people would do a lot of
projection
even when i was in the military proper
cut dressed always like to the tea
remember i was dating somebody this
person was indian and
when we would go out i remember one time
someone in the comments like oh you're
into thugs i'm like [ __ ] what
got a dress shirt on in my short i just
remember thinking about where did you
make that
but just see what people just make that
yeah definitely so
can't do anything about that's one of
the unfortunate parts of dating you know
it's like um and knowing this is
important
you know like if i date somebody from
another race they try to introduce me to
their parents i'm like you better tell
me
so i don't even like doing that anymore
because i'm like you better tell your
parents
because i'm not trying to meet them
because i already know they got their
things that they're going to project
they need some time
definitely to process whatever prejudice
state they may have
because it's generally awkward yup
but anyways those are our thoughts you
have anything else you want to add on
this topic
progression she was gorgeous though god
bless her yeah yeah absolutely
yeah i might be looking for some
beginner workouts so if you want to hit
me up
i'm saying one set of curls let's go
let's go one more bro let's go bro
that's right
uh but anyways let us know what you guys
think in the comments below hopefully
you guys enjoyed today's video
[Music]
you can